welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation titled lateral
flow assay development from lab-based
assay to diagnostics test prototype
introducing sativa's development
services platform it's my pleasure to
introduce you to lee jenkins senior
product leader saitiva for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the tab at the top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them via the q a box and our speaker
will address your questions at the end
of the presentation
please join me in welcoming lee jenkins
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
okay hi so thank you for introduction so
as introduced i'm lee jenkins and i'm
here to take you through accelerating
development
and a focus on saitvs development
services platform
so the presentation today is going to go
through these agenda points so i'll
start off with a overview of the common
development challenges
i'll move into a overdue decibel
diagnostic services
covering what it includes and how we
overcome development challenges
i'll go into a typical custom
development process and close with a
case studies and a quick q a so if
you've got any questions throughout the
presentation please feel free to come
into the chat and i'll pick them up at
the end of the call
so
uh going into a overview of the common
development challenges
so you can see on this slide that we've
outlined six different concepts which
we've had feedback typical challenges
for developers going through a new
product
launch
i'll spend a couple of minutes going
through each one talking about why it's
important to
yourselves going through the process you
know what the constraints are things you
need to be aware of but also you know a
little hint on how they can be overcome
and what we can help to provide
uh within the service
so starting on the first aspect which is
the access to experienced scientists so
one of the things about latter flows
which attracts people to developing them
as a product concept
is that they are pretty much unrivaled
among other types of rapid tests when it
comes to the speed and ease of use the
fact that it can be used by people away
from central labs they can be used at a
point of care or they can be using a
home-based sentence
however the ease of use can quite easily
you know give a little bit of a complex
development because
it's quite a highly informed
decision-making process you need to
have careful consideration of different
elements of the test including the
cellos the parts and other key
components
and it's quite easy to underestimate
that so access to a key
scientist who has done this before can
really help accelerate your development
at this stage
you also have the aspect of you know
someone who has produced these tests
before uh they were aware of the the
common risks and the setbacks their
experiences taught them from previously
you know it helps them to speed up the
iterative assay design process and it
can lead to a more optimal solution
that's you know saves your hunt to
repeat testing or repeat development at
a later stage
the third point is that you know
experienced staff also have knowledge of
what works and that can be quite key
because when you're developing a new
platform you know you have to start from
complete scratch but you might have a
scientist who knows you know what
detection particles work well with what
membranes and what parts for example and
it can significantly reduce your
development time as a result so all of
these are key to making sure that you
know you've been through your
development process as smooth as
possible
okay so the next part i'm going to take
you into is robustness of design
so under robustness of design you know
talking about the complexity in the
previous slide
it's very important that you manage that
complexity and that you've got a working
product at the end of it that is
substantially developed in order to
quantum market as it's intended to
so you need to be able to understand
issues from
lay person use so you're not going to
have clinicians in all instances using
these tests
so it has to be
error proof in some respects
it has to be able to work in different
humilities and temperatures and it has
to have a good stability over time
because you want to have your product on
the shelf for you know the longer term
as possible
they also need to be developed and this
one's quite important using the full
breadth of the product specification
so typically
doing development now it's important
that you get products from the extremes
of a specification
so you'll have a product with a
nominal or an average rating but within
the typical release it might vary and
you need to test that so make sure you
understand any variation stack within
your product so you don't want the
product to fall over once it's in the
field or the later stage as a result of
you know not enough
rigorous testing
and it's important that you consider all
these aspects during the design process
the third part is you know
the world we're all working in with
regards to the latter flow test is
typically a medical device framework
we all work into iso
13.5 and as much as possible you need to
ensure that everybody throughout your
process is working to the same standard
so
if you can have someone further down
your protest your development partners
or your component suppliers who are
qualified to the same standard it can
significantly you know reassure your
risk process you know you've got quality
products but also it can help with
audits trails and traceability of design
history files at the later stage
okay
the next framework which we're going to
touch on is the rapid prototyping of
designs
and you know this is something again
which as you go through the process it's
important that you're able to test your
ideas that you're able to work out how
successful your design is going to be as
early as possible in the process before
you start investing large amounts of
time of resource of you know of money in
this process
so rapidly getting from that idea to a
proof of principle or proof of concept
despite of
you know proving your idea to whether
it's your stakeholders whether it's your
investors
you know whatever it is that's going to
trigger that next milestone of
investment in the project
again key considerations here that how
do you work with different design
formulations in parallel to
avoid time and delays in the process
how to optimize the test conditions so
that they're repeatable and that you
don't get again variation later in your
process
how do you overcome and evaluate
commercial viability in a simple
low-cost way
and how do you access equipment and
skills needed to quickly develop
prototypes
you know in development stage you might
have a competing priorities between
trying to achieve all of these things
but at the same time you know you don't
want to invest in expensive
equipment or you don't want to hire
scientists when you can't give a
long-term commitment
to
how long they're going to be you know
required by your project
so being able to get rapid prototyping
and quickly prove your concepts is a key
part of the moment
the next one is access to funding so i
touched on on it a little bit in the
last slide how rapid prototyping quickly
can help you access funding but
you know it's key in any development
trying to prove as early as possible in
your project
the pro the concept is valuable
it's you know it releases the next phase
of funding but also it reinforces your
resources you do have you make sure you
spend them in the right places
and this can give you challenges and
competent priorities because there's
that type of how do you manage budget
constraints against the needs for proven
design and generating prototypes at the
same time
you know one potential way around this
is to look at the development and bursts
where you can outsource trenches of work
you need up front so that you know a
simple way of freeing up that investment
without having to over commit or process
resources because you get a very precise
package of work delivered
okay so two more points i've gotten here
the next one is about access to
infrastructure
and you can see in the image on the
slide a large bio dot reel-to-reel
dispenser
and the key part around this is that
making sure that when you're in your r d
process
it's key to get access to a working
fully kitted out diagnostic lab because
one of the critical challenges is making
sure you go from a
lab skill test or just a bench top you
know simple test that you've developed
yourself but then making sure it's
replicable on a large industrial scale
everybody wants that test which is going
to produce you know millions of uh sales
and you have to have a way of being able
to produce your product on the same
scale in order to achieve those sales
so the
going back to the funding and the
infrastructure elements
now
there's obviously a consideration of how
would you handle this can you purchase
can you lease equipment can you get
access to a lab which
if you access all this equipment in a
timely way at a low expense
it's going back to the you know being
able to prove your concept in a very
risk very timely ways that you can move
on with your project and get through
your milestones as quick as possible
and then probably the most important one
last of all is protection of ip
so now we've gotten a slide that your ip
is precious and the life budget life
blood your business
and that can't be underestimated
now ip is everything to new startups and
been able to protect that design did
everything
you got to make sure that everybody
you're working with the process at all
steps that you're holding onto lip that
there's no loss or
unnecessary sharing so choosing a
partner or choosing the right way to
work on your concept you know there's
important considerations that you get
that back at the end of the process
so that's why i'm going to go into the
next part of the presentation is going
from you know these six concepts
taking you through a process we
actually sativa we're trying to support
you we'll partner with companies to go
from an idea to a point of care test
so the comments on here is you know i
have a lab based test that could be
optimized into a commercially available
particular test but people don't know
how to do that or they don't know with
turn for advice or for support
we have the service which can help
provide the path from an idea or a
lab-based test to the approved rapid
diagnostic test
and you know looking at development the
challenges the frustrations the hurdles
we can work with you to overcome that in
a simple way we can use our experience
our infrastructure
the components we have and
the scale of sativa to help you know get
people through this process in a very
quick and timely way
so as i mentioned our service is titled
sativa diagnostic services
and essentially it's a way for people to
navigate between the development process
so it covers everything from networking
collaboration and transparency
you can see on this slide we have
essentially the series built up it's two
pillars on the left hand side then
there's two things on the right which
going back to those considerations from
earlier a key for everybody
so
the services
first of all is looking at training and
education
so for people who have this idea or they
have a biomarker or they are their laser
test but they've never built a latch or
flow
one of the
key elements we can offer is training
for people to help teach them the basics
of the process we can get them started
on
introduction to lots of flow teaching
typical
pitfalls and issues which you need to
avoid so that they can make sure that
the project was smooth and this can
either be in a classroom a on-site or
online education so we understand that
now with the current uh pandemic
situation that maybe classroom or
face-to-face isn't possible for
everybody at the moment
so we could use virtual approaches or
alternatively you know we're happy to
invite people we say to do so
to come to our our lab in germany and we
have a hands-on classroom session
the sessions can be tailored around
anything you want to know so typically
it'd be
you know
a couple of day session up to maybe four
or five days
where we can look through processes so
teaching dispensing protocols teach you
how to use a vehicle for spr analysis to
select your detection pairs
whether it's looking to use
dispensers whether it's looking to
do your component selection so which
membranes to choose what pulse choose
how to make sure that everything fits
together how to get rid of
any non-specific binding you know we can
do all of this within the framework you
know and the last but for the point is
looking at workshops so if you just have
a challenge with something you want help
coaching to overcome you can use our
expertise to help coach you through that
can be a hands-on in-depth session where
you know we can set you up so that
you're ready for the future and you know
what to do next time this issue appears
the second element of the service is the
development expertise
so again you know several different
forms this could take so it could be
methods development
so we can help with you to create sops
or to create you know this bring us
rigor to your process which was
mentioned earlier
we can look at methods transfer so we
can help you go between a development
size product into a manufacturing site
project or we can even help transfer you
into a contract manufacturing
organization
there is methods qualification so we can
help you with your validation and
verification of your designs
or it can be shorter you know little
informal bits of work look at
troubleshooting so
if you've got non-specific binding or if
you've got a low sensitivity or accuracy
test you can help optimize that
and then finally you know it's
outsourcing of development so this is
looking at the whole wing-to-wing in the
process so
taking it from that very early stage
right the way through to
a working manufacturing skill test which
we hang back to
you know obviously
a lot more comprehensive work
but again all in partnership and all in
open transparency of working together
throughout the process
the other two parts we bring
the iep protection and transparency so
you know we're happy to share everything
we're doing it's a discussion it's a
collaboration and we can talk through
step by step what's next in the process
you know in agreement on how we perceive
that each part of the process
if you're able to access the site we can
give
full access to see what we do and work
together during development or if it's
virtual we can you know provide all the
protocols electronically and have
regular future calls
but the important part of this is that
you know what i tested on earlier about
vip being survivor all of the ap
transfers back to the
original owner
at saitva we don't know any of this you
know you have everything back there's no
licensing and it's a clean handbag of
everything to do with that i say
materials and infrastructure
so you know you've seen a few images
throughout the presentation where we
have this working lab but you know we
can use our equipment and our processes
our staff to do everything from
stability trials
a lot of release testing complete
management so if you've got some
complaints and you can't work through
what's going wrong in the test we can
help with that or even more material
inspection and i've been incoming and
outgoing qt tests
okay so to move on for that you know
this is covering a typical customization
process and development process and how
we can work together so
you know product concept
is a very early stage idea of what you
want to achieve
going through to a custom design you
know if it's working with us you can
look at customization of membranes or
pads we can help work with any bespoke
designs you want whether it's a unique
cartridge or a unique lateral flow test
going across optimization and validation
so we can help with you know small scale
prototypes and then take it out onto a
larger scale
manufacturing so once you get your
product through and onto the market we
will support you from that stage and
then obviously ongoing support so
touching on this you know once you're in
the field
what you need is it a
regular supplier product or if you have
any sort of
performance issues we can help coach you
for that as well
so that's the presentation i have i'm
gonna just run a short video to conclude
the session and then i'll jump back on
to take any questions from the q a so
people feel free to put anything in the
chat and i'll come back to you and speak
to you shortly thanks everybody
my name
is i am the ceo of a biotech startup
that is called futano diagnostics we are
developing a disease diagnostic and
surveillance platform
where you put blood on the diagnostic
and in 10 minutes it tells you if the
patient has a ball or not
and then it sends a message to an online
platform and tells us where the patient
is located and then predicts where the
disease will spread for the past three
days we have been doing a diagnostic
development workshop in dassler our
experience with the coaching workshop
has been truly
educational
it is rare
to be able to speak about the science
the production and the business in one
conversation without a post because we
have a conversation
that moves from the technical bits to
the manufacturing to the business to the
intellectual property
something that is rare to find in the
past
three to four years that we've been
speaking to people about the work that
we do
being a lean starter
means that we don't have a lot of the
infrastructure and equipment that is
present at this facility
but being able to work with the
equipment and the facility
has helped us to see what we can grow to
become
and to envision what our
later stage rnd
and scaling up will look like
my name is charlotte masorum
i am the principal scientist at
retirement diagnostics this experience
has allowed us
to gain a better perspective
for where we want to be and what it
takes to get there
it has allowed us to
forecast potential challenges along the
way
and has allowed us to refine
and redefine our research and
development strategy and so the
different challenges we have been
addressing have been on simplifying
the interaction between our diagnostic
and the patient and improving the impact
of that for the next 18 months we will
definitely change our course the work
that we've been doing here has helped us
to reshape our r d strategy
and to become more efficient okay so the
next step is getting back to oxford
getting into the lab
and continuing with our with our r d and
continuing to refine
our product development pathway and make
our product at a
much more efficient pace because the
lessons that we've been getting in this
workshop
have saved us months of development so i
would definitely recommend that other
companies enter this competition program
has allowed us to be able to
have a
fuller more broader perspective
of
r d to manufacturing to distribution
and beyond to to the end user
thank you lee for that outstanding
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
question via the q a box
so our first question is can you give an
example of the type of tissue this
service can help with
okay thank you so
the example of the
time we work with previously is just um
we had one company who approached us to
help with troubleshooting of the assay
so
the
market but they were getting us with uh
accuracy of their results in the field
so we helped them identify what the root
cause was um specifically in this case
that
during development they only tested
components from the middle of the
specification ranges across several
items
and then as the product went into the
field there was issues with one of the
items still being in specification but
being slightly away from the
normal center of the
range and then this call was some
variation they would have gone to the
accuracy so after helping identify
the root cause we could very quickly
have to resolve the problem so um i
think this is a perfect
example of what we other examples are
like the hutano diagnostics video you
know as a customer we
we specifically took them from an idea
into the feasibility of the content
great okay i've got another question for
you
will saitima own the ip of any element
of the test post development
and now so hopefully i try to touch on
this as part of the presentation but
this question came in early
no so cyto sativa as a company we try to
be as transparent as possible so we make
sure that all the agreements up front um
specify this but we want all of the ip
back to the diagnostic developer now we
are not a diagnostic company our
interest in this is helping our
customers get to the market as quick as
possible
so the only iep we maintain is around
manufacture and supply of our components
otherwise everything else goes back to
the excuse me for the regulatory filing
of the test
okay thank you
third question
will sativa be able to help with the
manufacture of my test post development
so hopefully the person asking us in the
session earlier with john from underdone
health who were talking about um
contract manufacturing organizations
so at sativa you know we can't help with
the actual manufacture of the test
normally um you know encourage you to
get in contact with us to discuss this
but what we can't do is help with the
process of transferring into a contract
manufacturer
so we can help you go through the
process to make sure that everything is
developed that you have all the correct
protocols that you have identified a cmo
to work with and then we can help you
you know doing that process
if
anyone wants any more
advice or conversation around this
encourage them to get in contact or we
can discuss on a case-by-case basis
okay
our next question
is the service only available in europe
or is it worldwide
so it's worldwide so the resources for
this are currently based in germany so
in our
manufacturing site in dussel which is
where we produce our membranes such as
the nitrocellulose going into blood
products
but it's yes worldwide so
at present we have the germany base we
are looking into expanding into a china
base for 2021
um albeit will be on a smaller scale but
yeah open to work with any customers
across all regions
great thank you lee um next question
does sativa have loyalty to any specific
reagent supplier as part of their
development
so
two points i didn't know
so we have suppliers we work with and
generally based upon
what we feel about a quality product and
people we know with stable supply chains
and products
early available but if a customer has
any specific requirements we can discuss
this with them so if they have a
particular supplier they use in their
test or
people who don't want to use obviously
we're happy to consider us at the scope
of the project
the best approach for this would be for
the customer to again get in contact
with us and we can talk details about
what they want and understand you know
what their requirements are
okay
got another question
does this service have to be performed
at the saitiva site or can it take place
at the customer site
interesting question because given the
pandemic it's a slightly different slant
on this question i guess the normal
so before
the
whole world change due to the covert 19
and the current endemic we were looking
to take this as a series that we could
visit the sites
um honestly they would have to have a
diagnostic job and able to have the
resources to host
the sort of work involved
but we would also encourage people to
come visit us
in germany
but um the change and how we're working
now is that obviously we're not
traveling as much and people aren't
coming over to us
so we're working a lot more digitally
and by electronic means so a lot more
video calls up more skype and teams
calls
so you know happy to talk with a
customer on what works best best for
them but
it'd be digital in the future it could
be either approached
and on what they have available if they
come to germany it obviously allows us
to show the site and to
understand
manufacturing around the need to sell
those products etc
but um yeah case by case i'll be
discussing what works best for them
okay thank you lee our next question
are you looking at developing covid19
antigen lateral flow test
in the presentation that um we don't
know about our own tests you know when
we talk about ip and about customers
this is all about taking the projects
and helping them get into the market
quicker
so we're not developing our own
cooperating
but we do have some active projects we
are working on which are trying to do so
so we've had some press releases
previously
um if
there was probably people on the
internet with a little around but um
yes there was a project we're working on
and we're open to discussing anything
that people want to work with us on
okay our next question what is the
general timeline and cost from product
concept stage to manufacturing scale
so this question is very dependent on
what the customer is trying to achieve
so what the test is
um you know how many targets whether
it's a single or multiplexing
um
what stage for the concept they're at so
it is
awkward to give a
direct answer to this on the forum
probably
you know the best way would be for us to
contact the customer around this event
we can discuss you know directly what
they're trying to achieve
but
timelines
you know a typical diagnostic test you
would traditionally be looking
two to three years to go through a whole
development get through trials gets
around the market
around covered 19 we've been forced to
look at a lot shorter too so we
typically looking more than six months
for
the development and that's put a lot
more urgency and pressure on the
timelines but um yeah you know encourage
the customer we can talk to them
basically about what they're doing
understand their tests and then
a specific quote on whatever cost and
the timelines involved
okay looks like we have one more
question here
what are some of the factors that need
to be considered while transferring the
manufacturing process from one facility
to another
so again i mentioned earlier that
there's a presentation earlier today
from african health this was
specifically what the topic was about so
i can summarize quickly but john spent
you know
like a q a in depth in this topic so
i think this
look at that more details
so essentially it's all about ensuring
that the test has the correct level of
stability so that
you know it can go from a bench top
scale
and your conjugates once they drive
they're able to withstand they're
transferred to a larger manufacturing
process
that
you have a robust design so that it's
all transferable and that they worked
and handled
well it looks like he may have frozen up
lee
can you still hear us
okay well it looks like we've lost lee's
video so um any questions that are
submitted in the on-demand period can be
answered by the speaker via email thank
you again lee and thank you to the
audience for your outstanding questions
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months please
remember to share it with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on the
other presentations on our agenda visit
the agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing thank you again for your
participation and until next time
goodbye